what is up everybody welcome back it's
great to see you believe nation I'm
doing something a little bit different
today that I haven't done on previous
editions of my Evans book series my
publisher wrote to me with ten questions
that they want to use to help promote
the book and get publicity and attention
around it and then looking at the
questions I thought maybe I should make
a video about this because you guys
could help kind of understand the
mindset behind the book where I'm going
with it why I think it's so important
and I much rather speak then write out
answers the questions anyway so today's
episode of Evans book is going to be
answering the ten questions that came in
from my publisher and I'd love to know
what you guys think about it afterwards
leave a comment below or isn't going
along let's get into the questions so
the first one I came up is what
motivated you to start this movement one
of the things that I discovered about
myself and would believe my one word is
I hate untapped potential it drives me
nuts when I see somebody who's living
way below where they should be who's
playing a smaller game than they should
be it bothers me a lot it started off
with just the people around me the
people in my circle and it got bigger
and bigger and bigger and to the point
now where I want to be able to have a
bigger impact on people I think for all
of you who have this skill will have an
ability to to make a change a spark a
shift to make the world better in some
way then you owe it to yourself and to
others to go and do it there's nothing
worse than somebody who has a ton of
skill and potential and they never
realize it and instead of being the
Michael Jordan that whatever you could
be right everybody has Michael Jordan
level talent at something and instead of
being that Michael Jordan in your field
in your particular industry you're an
accountant at Starbucks and nothing
wrong with being accountant at Starbucks
you know I love accountants I love
Starbucks Howard Schultz is a founder of
Starbucks is on my wall but it's not
what you were supposed to do you could
be doing so much
better and you know 95% of the world
wakes up and plays small everyday and it
bothers me it just bothers me and so
that was the the start of all this you
know the mission that I'm on is I wanna
be able to help a billion entrepreneurs
and that makes me want to do things on a
bigger scale whether it's write the book
whether that's making YouTube videos I'm
not so much into the one-on-one coaching
you know I don't sell business coaching
services it's not the game I want to
play I want to be able to do something
on a much bigger impact and so what I
think about what I encourage people
watching and reading the book is that I
want you to know that you could do
something so much bigger with the
potential that you have inside you there
have been days and maybe it's every day
when you think about I know I could be
doing more than this I feel like I'm
wasting my time and wasting my talents
and this limited amount of time that we
have on this planet to go and do
something special I want you to do
something that you can make you proud
make your kids proud make your grandkids
proud that the story of you will carry
on for generations because of the
amazing impact that you had in this life
and most people don't do that
most people again are living small and
so that motivates me that's why I want
this movement to take off that's why I
want you guys to read the book that's
why I feel that it's so important and
that's the love energy heart and passion
is flowing through those pages that
really mean something to me that's a
good first question I'm excited let's we
got you have nine more let's go through
it number two your one word is believe
can you explain how you chose this word
when I was getting started in this
process I didn't even know that there
was this one word concept it wasn't this
book did not exist right so I had to
stumble and fumble my way through it you
know wasn't a publishing game right I
had a website I still have a website and
and it just felt like I was in the views
game just trying to get lots of views
just trying to sell advertising and I
felt like I could do something more
important the work wasn't as fulfilling
as I felt I felt that it could be and I
was having a hard time explaining what I
did and for people to pick up the
message and so I thought the problem was
actually a tagline problem I thought it
was well I need to say Evan Carmichael
and then you know helping entrepreneurs
or over 20
entrepreneurs helped and Counting that
was one of my tag lines before or you
know inspiration and motivation for
entrepreneurs and and I struggled on
what what it was that I wanted to be
known as and what I later realized was I
was really struggling with who who am I
actually not just how I want to present
myself to the world but Who am I
actually as a human being and how can I
flow that through everything that I do I
started thinking about who I was and
there was a couple things that happened
along my journey one I watched the the
jobs movie with Ashton Kutcher that was
inspiring to me and then I watched this
jobs clip which is one of my favorite
clips of all time where he's talking
about marketing and he's talking about
marketing being about values it's not so
much just about whatever product or you
know service you're selling not the
features or benefits but the values the
values that you stand for as a company
as people selling through your values
that's what marking is really all about
it's like I think what's what I'm what's
my value what do I stand for what do i
what do I believe in and I just started
making a list I mean a list of all these
different words or sentences that I that
I resonated with it was just spitballin
it's just like whatever came into my
head pounded down in the paper and see
what happens and I made this notepad
file and I went through just whatever
came to head to my mind and believe was
actually somewhere in the middle of that
list but in the end of the day I didn't
know you know I didn't feel like I had I
had it I didn't know what I what I was
you know wanted to rally around yet so I
slept on it the next day I woke up I
looked on my list again and believed
just kind of popped off the page for me
but then I thought it was too big like
it's too big a word Who am I to be
believed you know it's every believe is
so big and I'm only dealing with
entrepreneurs you know at least I
thought at the moment and other people
have done believe before people really
doesn't believe campaigns how am i
unique or different and you know what do
you guys think and so I struggled to
make it more complicated you know I
would okay believe in yourself or
believing in your business or believe in
your passion or like I would add all
these other things on to it and you know
that day I still didn't feel like I had
it I still didn't feel like I knew what
I wanted to do none of them really
popped off and then I woke up the next
day and you know what I just felt like I
just like believed I just liked that one
word I just like that
one idea then I thought can I do this
crazy thing and build a business and
build a life around one word around
believe that said it seems too simple do
you know how can a person be defined by
just one word and I just started doing
little experiments I did my newsletter
as a tax I did my YouTube channels
attached just one video I like to prove
things that they work on a small scale
before expanding and through the book it
guides you through different experiments
to test because I don't want you
spending your time is one of the things
that we have not enough of it's our most
precious asset so I don't want you off
spending time on something and it's not
working I don't want you just take my
word for it that it works I want you to
apply it and test it in small ways and
see okay dissection feels good oh I'm
getting some results okay what's the
next thing
and then slowly helps you go from the
three seconds our core campaign company
you figure out who you are your core you
start to apply it in a campaign small
tasks make sure you get in some wins
before you bring it to a company and
start making major major major changes
and decisions that's how I came to
believe and I needed to prove to myself
that it worked I need to prove to myself
that this wasn't just some crazy idea
but that I could get results and
everything that I tried around believe
instantly did way better way way way
better than anything else that I had
ever done and so I decided to do this
crazy thing and build my entire business
and my life around believe and because I
felt that power I then thought well
maybe other people could benefit from
this as well because this just means
this took them it only fits for me
you're good other people use it too and
just the people in my around me started
saying well what's happening like the
gorillas growth just you're more
confident you have more passion you're
getting so much better results what
happened and I was actually a little shy
a little nervous to say well you know I
did this thing I you know this one word
idea and it's a lot since you're saying
explain it to me give me some help on it
and then I would help other people find
their one words and then see them start
to have major improvements and changes
in their lives and if I allowed this
thing actually like this could be not
just for me this could be for everybody
and then part of the research in the
book was building a company around the -
so finding other people who built entire
businesses around their one word from
$50,000 full time income guy too
half a million dollars in revenue two
million dollars to five million dollars
to 150 million dollars and I found by
talking to entrepreneurs and traveling
across North America talking to these
people that they didn't have the plane
either they didn't have the blueprint
the book wasn't written for them either
they just kind of stumbled onto it and
it felt right just like it felt right
for me and so the goal with the book is
to be able to provide all of those
stories into one easy to digest and
apply blueprint for you to be able to
build your life and your business around
your ones number three how do you help
people find their one word in their
credo so this is a great question some
people I find as soon as you ask the
question they already know some people
are they just they just know that wasn't
me I took I took a lot of time to try to
figure it out for the people who know
it's great it's time to move on to the
next exercise so the people who don't
there's a couple of things that we look
at on the guide people through a five
step process to find out what their one
word is some of the things to think
about our making a list of everything
that makes you happy thinking about this
is not just a New York resident just
what makes you happy today is what's
always make you happy so think about
your favorite songs even songs growing
up your favorite movies your best
friends what did you love about your
parents what if you loved about your
favorite teacher you know write all
those things down and then what what is
the common trait between them why do you
like this music and what does that have
to do with your favorite teacher at
school there's a there's a common trait
between all those things that have
connected all your happiness for your
entire life and it's finding out what
that is and so for me it's believed my
parents they're on the wall here behind
me my parents always would tell me that
was a kiss Trilly Carmichael and I can
do anything that I wanted my mom's last
name is ghost really my dad's I say miss
Carmichael my middle name is ghost
really so I was a cast rlly Carmichael
and I could do anything that I wanted
and that's that's belief right that's
what believe is all about I love the
underdog stories my favorite movie is
Seabiscuit it's about this horse and
jockey and owner that everybody thought
you know would never work
there all these guys who are down on
their luck and not having success and
then they come together and they're this
huge underdog that goes on to win and I
love those kind of stories you
the people that I respect most and like
dealing with most are the ones who push
people to be better that believe in them
when they're down so all of these things
that came across my life the common
theme was belief so that's one way to
look at it you can look at it as the
negative what are some of the negative
things in your life that that have been
constant as well what what do you hate
some people find this a lot easier
instead of going to the positive go to
the negative what do you hate in the
world what do you hate
like I hate being around these kind of
people can you access that emotion
easily what are those kinds of people
that you absolutely can't stand being
around and then the opposite is gonna be
your one word right like that's your
anti word the opposite is going to be
what you do like and what you do stand
for so it's a couple the ways that the
book guides you through that process to
try to figure out what it is that you
actually stand for and then what happens
is a really interesting thing because
once you realize what you do stand for
and especially the first part of this
book can apply to everybody you don't
have to be an entrepreneur you don't
have to be in business it's just
self-awareness and understanding because
when you find that one word when you
find out what really really really
matters to you you're gonna find that
there are some areas in your life that
are incongruent with that one word that
are out of alignment where you're acting
small where you are not taking the steps
that you should and you feel bad about
it but you're afraid of something you're
afraid of judgment you're afraid of
failure whatever it is you're afraid of
something and so you're playing small
you're playing small and then you
discover you actually realize you're
playing small and instead of just
ignoring it like you usually do every
day you just ignore it and maybe
complain about it you realize that you
have to take some action on it it's very
liberating and that you realize that
listen I have control I can do this I
can change my life around this area
because I haven't been living to my
potential here but it's also scary in
that some of those changes might be
painful and that's where you see so much
growth in people who go through this
exercise after they really figure out
who they are and this is something that
we teach most people are not equip most
people don't have the tools most people
haven't been told how to do this they
don't teach this in schools and
universities and so it's it's just such
a powerful experience that guy
people through and I'm so grateful for
having found it in terms of the credo
the credo is the second part after you
find your one word when when you look at
my word I believe believe has a
connotation it has an understanding that
most people will associate with and I
think for most people you think believe
is being self-confident believe in
yourself and that's definitely part of
it but what you need to do is once you
identify what your one word is then
break it down into three different
components that change it from just the
word believe to hash tag believe I'm
labeling it now this is what believe
means to me and very often you'll have
the common definition but there'll also
be some other things that make up your
one word that aren't as obvious they're
obvious to you but they're not obvious
to everybody else and that's how you can
say I'm not just about this one word the
common definition that's when people
feel like finding your one word I'm not
just one word on multiple words how can
you just put me in that box of one word
you get to create your own box you're
not just limited by the standard
definition of that box by other people
so belief for me is yes believe in
yourself the self confidence but also
believe in what you're doing is super
important to me having passion for the
work that you're involved in day to day
is important so believe in what you're
doing and also believe that it's gonna
work out to have the conviction to
follow through to persist every day keep
going that even if you don't know how
it's gonna work out believe that it will
work out and so for me hashtag believe
breaks down into self confidence passion
and conviction it's really important for
you to then identify for yourself after
you find your one word what are the
three things that make that up and then
look at your life and look at your
business and look at what you're doing
every day how much of what you're doing
is in alignment are you around people
that make you feel those things are you
teaching others in your life around
those things you know if you have a team
are you guiding your team along those
things and making them feel more believe
or family or justice or integrity or
whatever your one word is you should be
a planet with a gravitational pull for
that one word where everything around
you now has to start to get better you
are a missionary for
or that cause I'm a missionary for
believe if you are around me on my team
watching my channel reading the books
the more time you spend around me the
more you are going to believe in
yourself in others and the things that
you're working on it's just going to
happen and I want that same thing for
you whatever is most important for you I
want you to be a beacon of light and
then spread that to others and it starts
with you believing it yourself and then
the people around you and then slowly it
expands and experience and experience
and so finding the Credo is that next
step and then we can work on building a
campaign around that building a company
around it but the core section is so
super important because most people
don't have the self-awareness to know
what they actually really stand for and
you look at most companies yeah okay a
company has a list of 15 core values
here's what we stand for
hoorah all right great go talk to
anybody in that company and ask them if
they know what the core values are ask
the CEO if he knows what those core
values are I bet you almost nobody will
be able to do it and so you can't even
say what the what the 15 or 10 or
whatever core values are of your
business then how are you you're
supposed to use this as it's the lens to
which you see the world right this is
how you see the world through the SCORM
it's how you make the important
decisions in your life and business
through these carbides you're gonna
remember what they are
then you're not making important
decisions you're not using them you're
not leveraging them and so finding the
one thing that one word that breaks down
into three makes it just so much so much
so much easier for people to remember
number where are we for what's the
biggest problem facing entrepreneurs
today how can your book help fix it I
think the biggest problem facing
entrepreneurs honestly is so many people
get into it for the wrong reasons I
think so many people get into being an
entrepreneur cuz they're trying to make
money because they're just trying to
make a quick buck because they they
pulled up a copy of a magazine to show
them the 10 hottest businesses to start
this year and so they go off and do that
and if your goal is just for the money
you're never gonna make it it's just not
you look at the most successful
entrepreneurs you look at you look at
jobs and Winfrey and gates and all these
people who started great businesses or
whoever you most respect to look up to
you look at why they started their
business it was never just to make money
they wanted to have an impact they
wanted to change the
way that things were done in the
industry you look at Steve Jobs who was
a multi-millionaire in his 20s he could
have retired he could have gone on and
done anything else that he wanted he had
all the money that he needed for the
rest of his life in his 20s and what did
he do he kept working at Apple until the
day he died he was working at Apple with
the stint where he was forced to leave
in the middle but like till the day he
died working at Apple and not making
money his top priority what happened
Apple became the most successful the the
most valuable company in the world at
the time under his leadership and you
see it over and over and over and over
again where if you make a decision just
just for the money you're gonna quit
because entrepreneurship is hard because
one of the hardest things you're ever
gonna do in your life as soon as it gets
tough you're gonna quit you're gonna go
find something else because this is why
why put up with all the crap and all the
pain and all the suffering if you're not
getting the reward with the reward is in
the work not the outcome the real reward
is in doing the work I write the book
because I want to write the book yes i
won I want the goal of having you guys
read it but I like the process I make
these videos because I like I want to
make the videos yes I want to get
millions of subscribers great that's a
goal but if I'm if that's my only goal
to have a million subscribers and oh my
my attitude and mindset shifts the
actions I take [ __ ] where even if I
never hit a million subscribers I'm
gonna keep doing this because I love
doing it until the day that I stop love
doing it and then I'm gonna find
something else to do and that is what
successful entrepreneurs have in common
they love the work they love their craft
they would do it even they weren't
getting paid for it and then they add so
much value that they end up getting paid
a lot of money for it so money is
important I'm not saying I'm not saying
mine is not important I'm saying don't
chase the money it's just don't chase
only the money and that's why too many
people get into business I'm only
looking to make a buck and it's not
working so I quit into something else in
terms of how this book ii by that
question was how can your book help fix
it
I think the self awareness helps fix it
I think understanding who you are as a
person what you really stand for what
means the most to you what what you
value most will help
you picked the right opportunities if
you are all about honesty if that's what
your thing is then there's a lot of
businesses that you know you don't want
to be involved in and the way that you
set up and run your business will be
very different than a lot of other
companies you know you don't want to
play in that gray zone you definitely
want to play in in you know the the
negative territory so how that
self-awareness will help you make better
decisions and not just in business but
in life where if you've doubted yourself
you haven't had confidence you don't
know if you should take this path or
this path a lot of it comes down to you
not having enough self-awareness you not
knowing who you are what you stand for
because figuring that out this again is
the lens to which you see the world and
make all the important decisions it's
one of the most important exercises
you'll ever do in your life and so it
makes every business decision that you
make easier more effective stronger more
true to you more impactful and more
likely to have an impact on your
customers your partner's your suppliers
and media as well so once you figure
that out what your mission is what you
stand for your one word then the book
guides you through how to apply that to
a campaign I want you to get sales from
it right I want you to make money from
your one word right I want you to be
able to hire people build a team have an
impact you know get a bigger house cool
on that vacation buy the cars that you
want right I want you to be able to do
that and so it starts with having a
campaign and again like I talked to
before I want this to work for you yeah
I want to I want I have to prove it to
you that this works you have to prove it
to yourself you shouldn't just blindly
follow anybody prove that it works this
is a small test to prove that it works
that you're getting some results and
then from there to help you build out
the rest of your campaign and build
another company from hiring the team
from raising capital from you know
building a culture from how to fire
people how to onboard people all of that
stuff matters
and so the book guides you through the
process but again every step along the
way you're proving to yourself that it's
working having an impact that it feels
good and you get results next what is an
example of a great workplace culture
this is an interesting thing because I
look at which was the book it was built
the last was it built to last yeah
built to last by Jim Collins who looked
at companies that were built to last
that lasted forever that have been
around for a hundred plus years and he
looked at what were some of the factors
behind it and one of the most important
things was having having the culture and
so if you have Walt Disney on that list
which they were and I think was Philip
Morris one of the cigarette companies
were on that list as well these two
companies obviously have very different
cultures right you know Disney wants to
make kids really happy tobacco company
wants to you know maybe sell cigarettes
to kids very different cultures but they
work for them and so that's what I found
consistently as well in dealing with the
companies I interviewed in the book from
the people who the $50,000 full time
income guy was just himself but he then
partners up with suppliers and
contractors who come on board he's all
about awesome roberto blake is the
50,000 entrepreneurs all about awesome
so he wants to create awesome work you
have to want to create awesome work in
Roberto's eye so if you are a supplier
to him if you are contract with him if
you're a partner with him you have to be
focused on creating an awesome product
an awesome experience if that's not part
of what you're all about then you're not
gonna work out well together
trauma then it's also the next business
we look at that has half a million
dollars in sales and has a team of 10
instructors or so and then 40 or 50
helpers as well we're a part of it
they're all about family so it's about
not judging others as though being
welcoming being opening you know so it's
not it's not just about teaching how
somebody had to do a dance move but
making them feel like they're home and
so you recruit teachers instructors and
assistants and volunteers who all
believe in the same thing and as a
result you get students who all believe
in the same thing as well and the thing
is for all of these cultures you look at
my my business it's all about belief
right and we have 16 people on the team
right now as with this recording some
people look at believe and say that's
stupid believe is so stupid like I don't
care about believe I just want to be a
programmer that's really a stupid
message amazing don't apply I don't want
to work with you you don't want to work
with me we would just be fighting the
whole time and I think this is
where a lot of people make bad decisions
and hiring and in as if you're an
employee and looking at taking on a job
they just look at the paper you just
look at oh do they have the skills all
right I'm trying to hire a programmer
okay great do they have the programming
skills yes perfect okay let's give them
a programming test see if they can solve
these problems they did it perfect great
hiring them on board meanwhile they
don't believe in the mission they don't
have the same values that I have right
you can't just marry somebody without
understanding who they are without going
on dates right and talking about
important life things that you believe
in to your core if you love honesty and
they are dishonest who cares
if they can produce great code it's not
gonna create an amazing culture so it
doesn't matter what your one word is no
judgement there's no judgement that you
have the right one word or the wrong one
word you know yours doesn't have to be
believe for it to be a good one word you
got to find the thing that is right for
you there's no perfect business
there's just the perfect business that
is for you and so the best cultures are
the ones where the the founder truly
believes in that mission in that one
word and what they're all about and then
articulates it to attract a team that
believe in the same thing and if
everybody is on the same page if
everybody shares the same values then
you need to make sure you've got that
plus the skills and that's a great
culture because most of the conflicts
that happen really are just about
different values in relationships and
businesses the big conflicts that happen
are about different values somebody
values speed and somebody values doing
it right I don't care if it has you know
a couple mistakes we need to get it out
by this day no you know it has to be
perfect and those two people will
constantly fight because they have
different values different belief system
and so you need to make sure that you
know what your belief system is through
your one word and then bring on a team
of people who believe in the same thing
and again it doesn't matter what the run
one word is as long as it's true to you
and it's true to the people that you
hire and bring them for it that makes
your Greek culture number six do you
think anyone can be an entrepreneur
that's an interesting question I think
everybody has it in them I think
everybody has an idea of what they want
to do that could be
I think everybody's had an idea of a
product or service that they want to
start I think more than being an
entrepreneur though I think everybody
could have more potential because people
may not have the risk tolerance to be an
entrepreneur you know they may not have
the fortitude to handle the ups and
downs of being an entrepreneur and so I
think that's what people may fall down I
think that's what holds people a lot
back from being an entrepreneur I think
everybody has his ideas for what they
could do I don't know if everybody could
be an entrepreneur but I think almost
everybody could be playing bigger you
know you can be playing bigger you know
that what you're doing right now is not
the best of you you're not giving it
everything you have limiting beliefs
you're holding yourself back in a lot of
areas in your life some consciously some
unconsciously you could play bigger and
most people don't have somebody to push
them to do it most people don't have the
self-awareness to do it most people
don't know why they're playing small and
that's what the book helps expose when
you know what you stand for and you
compare that to what you're actually
living in your life you realize there's
a lot of stuff that I'm not doing right
that I'm not doing as I should do that
I'm not doing that is in accordance with
who I truly am and so that leads you to
play small it leads you to live in fear
and so instead of going off and doing
that big thing whether it's being an
entrepreneur or just switching careers
or starting something else or being with
a different person right it has so many
ramifications on your entire life I
think everybody could be playing a
bigger game I think everybody has
potential is untapped and that's what
I'm trying to unlock with this book next
who is one person you hope reads this
book you I hope you read this book I
hope you've been watching this or
listening to this or hearing this you
heard something in there that makes you
feel like yeah he's talking to me that
you're not playing big enough that you
could be doing a lot more with your life
that you're not satisfied with the the
the people in your life what you've
accomplished what you think you could do
I hope you read this book I hope you
read it I hope you think about it I hope
you apply the lessons and I hope you
write to me I hope you write to me and
tell me what you think if you have
questions let me know
but I hope you apply it I hope you have
the courage to apply it because a lot of
this what its gonna do is shine a light
I like them I've got like the Sun on me
here the shining light on me as I'm
saying it it's gonna shine a light on a
lot of things in life that you're not
doing well at and that you know but you
may not be admitting to yourself and
it's gonna give you the steps and what
to do to get through it but are you
gonna have the courage to go out and
actually do it and so I really encourage
you not to just read another book
because you've read a thousand books and
maybe you've highlighted the books but I
want you to actually take some action on
the book follow the exercises just trust
that it works and let me show you some
results because you don't get results by
just reading you could be the smartest
person in the room but you're not gonna
get anywhere - you actually take some
action you'll see people who are way
less smart than you who have waved fewer
resources in you who you know shouldn't
be the ones making it but they do
because they did something about it just
having the idea for a great product or
service isn't enough just having the
idea to want to change something in your
life isn't enough you got to actually
take some steps and so I hope you read
it and more than that I hope you apply
some of the lessons and then let me know
how it's going on number eight
do you think established companies can
learn from your book what's one example
you would like to read your book what's
what's an example of one you'd like to
read your book it's interesting when I
first thought of this concept my my
thinking is so geared towards
entrepreneurs to the individual person
that I never even thought getting into
this business I would do anything with
corporations I thought they wouldn't
want to have me come in and speak at
their events because I would tell their
people that Gopi Hutchison it's not
fortunately this company so I never
thought I would have a corporate message
but it's surprising how effective the
message is in companies as well as I
said earlier on in this interview every
big company we're talking about
corporations now every established
company has that list of their core
values you can pull up any company go to
their website write they've been around
for a little bit have a sizeable you
know list of employees they all have
their core values written down there and
nobody follows them nobody follows them
you know you show up on day one you get
this huge
employee handbook of all the things that
you believe in in the processes and
procedures and blah blah blah nobody
reads it nobody really remembers it the
idea behind having a core value is that
you use it to make the important
decisions in your life if it's an easy
decision to make
then you don't have to worry about it
because it's and he says you're just
going to logically take action on it but
it's what is a hard decision it's when
the decision doesn't really necessarily
make sense financially because the devil
comes carrying a bag of cash so here's
the decision that you got to make an
important answer on do you take the cash
you take the logical way out or you or
do you do what's right how do you know
what's right your values tell you what's
right and what's right for me is maybe
not what's right for you and that's
totally cool but most companies don't
live their values period they couldn't
even name their values you can't name
your values how you going to live your
values and so I think that's one of the
biggest exercises that the big companies
need to go through starting from the top
the CEO what does he or she stand for
what's the most important thing for this
person and hopefully this alignment
somewhere down the path right well you
look at a new CEO comes in to a company
they often replace their management team
they often replace the VPS and the
people under them why is that it's not
just because you want to hire your
friends it's because you know these
people share the same values you got to
be working on the same page and so this
is a tricky thing for a company because
somebody comes in the CEO comes in or
existing CEO great reads the book picks
it up and says you know what that's
right we're not living our values we
don't even know what our 10 values are
you know you do a survey of all your
employees and nobody comes back and will
to name them that's a problem so okay
great we're gonna start living up to our
one word what's I want word I'm gonna
start with me mine is this great here's
what it's all about our company now
stands for this the tough part is how
many other people in your company feel
the same way and if you guys have been
fighting at all if people aren't getting
along if the project's not moving
forward as you want them to it's because
you have a clash about
and the hard part is this is the harder
it's harder the bigger your company gets
you're gonna have more and more and more
and more people who are none aligned
with what the CEO stands for that's a
problem most CEOs would just ignore it
because it's too it's too big it's too
big a deal it's too painful can you
imagine if you had to let go of 30% of
your team because they didn't fit the
values of what you stand for and finding
replacements for those people a short
amount of time it's crazy it's suicide
but if the company really wants to grow
if the CEO is really visionary the CEO
really wants to do something special and
that's what has to get done so I'm
excited to see how this is applied in
the corporate setting and I understand
that there's processes and things can
take time and it's may not being instant
decision but I would love to see big
companies stand for something powerful
meaningful important to them and then
actually live it I think about CVS
health and CVS decided that health was a
part of what they did and they changed
her name to CVS health and then they
looked at what they were selling in
their stores and they were selling
cigarettes and they thought you know
what if we are about health how can we
sell cigarettes the decision is
incongruent with who we are and what we
believe in and so they made a decision
to cut all cigarette sales from their
stores costing them two billion dollars
in revenue you don't just make up two
billion dollars in revenue that's gonna
cost their company that's gonna hurt
their share price it's gonna cost your
employees it's gonna cost them a lot of
money but it's the right thing to do for
them because they're about health and so
that's how your one word helps you it
helps to make the tough decisions when
the devil comes with a bag of cash so
CVS is about health that's what they did
and their stories shared in the book the
guy behind me Howard Schultz started
Starbucks his word is love there's a
story in the book too about Howard
Schultz in love one of my favorite
stories about Howard Schultz he wanted
to build the company that his father
couldn't work for his father he grew up
you know the wrong side of the tracks
lower-class his dad was a blue-collar
worker who hurt himself one day on the
job and there was no workers
compensation and so he had to go for
weeks without an income and it was
insanely hard on the family and he vowed
to create a business that his dad would
be proud to work for and so I really
clearly remember this one video of
Howard Schultz talking to her loser
meeting when Starbucks is one of the
first companies maybe the first of the
big companies to stand up and support
gay marriage and to say that we
recognize and think that's important and
he took a lot of heat for that he took a
lot of heat and there's one video of him
in a shirt who's meeting in a
shareholder stands up and say hey this
is you know it's great supporting gay
marriage you know awesome but Howard
this is going to hurt our stock price
you're CEO you're responsible for us as
shareholders to give us a return on our
investment so don't take the
controversial stance please because we
want to protect the value that we've
invested into your company and Howard
stands up and he says you know what the
lens through which we made this decision
was not a financial one it was the right
thing to do it's powerful and that
decision is made easier because he knows
that he's about love and if you're about
love your one word is love how do you
say that gay marriage is not right how
do you not stand with your team behind
it so even if it doesn't make logical
sense short term financially it's the
right thing to do and the right thing
pays off because the people on his team
who also stand for love love him even
more for taking the stance the customers
who come in love that he's taking a
stance and they want to buy more and
they want to tell their friends and I'm
telling the store to you guys and I'm
telling stories in the book where the
worst thing you can do it just be
vanilla be boring be safe
be corporate and so I really hope that a
lot of corporations picked this up and
I'm super excited to see who actually
runs with it do you think people can use
your book in their personal lives in
addition to their professional 100%
we've talked about some of these
concepts
ready but your one word becomes the lens
through which you see the world and when
I did the test audience for this book I
sent it to half entrepreneurs and half
non entrepreneurs and everybody loved it
especially the first section I think the
first section of core applies to
everybody the second section of campaign
and company applied to a more I don't
think just entrepreneurial sense but
more corporate professional world if
you're at a job it can apply to you know
helping your company get better in the
campaign and company but the first
section encore the first huge chunk of
the book is all about you figuring out
what you're all about and you apply that
to everything in your life you apply
that to your partner I'm able to
connecting your marriage better or find
the right person for you to marry it you
apply it to how you raise your kids
believe is what I'm all about
so one of the things that I do with my
son every time I pick up from school is
we have this little thing just like my
parents did for me is I will say I'm
Hayden Carmichael and I can do and here
he is seven years old he'll go anything
so I'm Hayden Carmichael and I can do
anything because I want him to believe
it impacts everything that I do I
believe in you guys I believe in the
people around me I believe in my son I
believe in my wife I believe in my
parents i sat down and had a hard
conversation with my parents saying that
I thought that they could be played at
bigger game that's rough who wants to do
that and they've done a lot by most
people's standards and I think they
could do more I think you can do more
and knowing what I'm all about knowing
how important this is to me gives me the
courage and confidence to move forward
on that path to be even bolder in my
next move and so it's going to
definitely absolutely 100% shine a light
on both what you're doing in your
personal life and your professional life
I don't you know pretend to be a
marriage counselor
or you know parenting guru or expert but
it's well it's definitely some of the
ways that people look at how they apply
their one word and I can see honestly a
lot of spin-offs like your one word for
parenting your one word for
relationships and partner up with
somebody who has that domain expertise
to then apply it and take it further but
you're definitely going to want to apply
it you're definitely gonna want to make
changes you can't help it you're gonna
see the incongruence it's gonna bother
you you're gonna want to do something
about it and so it can apply to both
both lives 100% last question what's
next for the movement where do you want
to see it go my mission is a billion
entrepreneurs that's what motivates me I
want to do things that can have a big
impact what I want to see is in terms of
the context of this movement the one
word movement I have seen such a
tremendous impact on the people that
have gone through this exercise first
myself second to the people that I've
personally coached and mentored and
helped from my friends and family in you
know some circles beyond that
entrepreneurs that I have masterminds
with and just seeing how people can
consume this and make so many fast
changes to their lives and businesses my
goal with this book with this part of
the movement is I wanted to reach
further I want more people to to
understand it to embrace it to apply it
to test it to see if it works for them I
want people to get real meaningful
results I want people to live up to
their potential I want people to have
confidence and a sense of purpose and a
sense of direction and feel like they
know what they're doing to know what
decisions to make that's what I hope
happens that's where I want to see it
going whether it's buying the book or
the audiobook or the e-book and with the
videos attached to all that stuff
whatever way you consume information
best I want people to pick it up I want
people to do the exercise I want people
to start making positive changes in
their lives and then I want you to start
impacting others I want people to see
how much growth that you've had in your
life how much more confident you are how
much more certain you are how much
better decisions you're making how much
happier you are that people look at you
I think what happened why are you so
happy now well why do you have so much
energy and passion what's going on I
want you to be a role model for others I
want you to touch their lives after you
touch your own - and I think I think the
world would be a much better place if
every
but he was doing things where they can
live up to their potential and live
through their values
so something excited by I'm super
excited this is the first time it's
coming out and I'm just so pumped to see
the results and I'm really curious to
hear your feedback and hopefully you'll
you'll hit me up with questions and in
results and I'd love to see your
progress along this path because I think
it could make a really big impact on
your own personal life on your friends
on your community and on your country
and on the world so thank you guys for
giving me the chance to answer these
questions it's been a lot of fun allowed
me to dive deep and answer some things
that I don't know that I've gone into
before so hopefully that helped you guys
watching I'd love to know what you think
if you have a question for me question
about the book question with the book
writing process leave it down the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do in terms of making reply coming up
soon thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love guys I'll see you
soon